today on the matt walsh show abc stages
a ritual shaming of one of their
bachelor contestants who's been falsely
accused of racism
and she of course goes along with the
spectacle also five lines including
uh more fallout from the revelation that
the catholic church is apparently still
catholic and ellen page now elliot
has her breasts amputated this is
something we're supposed to celebrate
in our daily cancellation a racism
controversy that's caused
cbs to shut down its daytime talk show
and
investigate they've got to investigate
it we'll talk about that and much more
today
on the matt walsh show
now at the beginning of this year i
didn't anticipate that i would end up
spending
you know a significant amount of time
discussing the bachelor on this program
the bachelor is
after all everything i hate about pop
culture condensed into one reality show
the bachelor's also everything i hate
about reality shows condensed into one
reality show
and it's still both of those things all
the more so recently but the racial
drama surrounding
the show in recent months is so
illustrative and instructive
that it's it's worth paying attention to
on those grounds
uh it's become a stage upon which the
macabre pageantry of cancel culture has
played out
and all of the worst features of cancel
culture its cruelest tendencies its most
fraudulent aspects as well
have been on full display so to briefly
review very briefly before we get to the
latest in this soap opera rachel rachel
kirk cannell
was a contestant on the bachelor she
eventually went on to win the show
which i think means that the bachelor
guy has to marry her or something i'm
still not clear on those details
but in any case it came out that rachel
three years ago at the age of 21
attended an old south themed frat party
there was nothing unusual about that at
the time those kinds of frat parties
were quite common
though probably not common anymore now
that it's clear that attending such a
party can ruin your life so probably we
won't be seeing those anymore
of course it was determined that the
only reason a college girl would go to a
frat party like that
is that she hates black people and so
she was condemned as a racist
i mean there's no other reason right no
one could conceive of any other reason
why somebody would have
went to that kind of party she
apologized repeatedly but that didn't
matter
um at all and then the former host of
the show chris harrison
initially defended rachel against the
canceled mob and was accused of racism
for defending her
and then he was promptly removed as host
and replaced with a black man named
emanuel acho
who used to be a football player but now
makes his living as a race-baiting tv
personality
the bachelor himself matt james also a
black man and a former football player
a turned businessman uh and so that that
about
sums it up i think that gets us up to
speed that's that's what's going on
there
rachel was canceled for going to a party
the host was canceled for defending the
girl who was canceled
and that brings us to the special that
aired on abc last night
it was decided that apparently this
whole issue with the frat party
had not been hashed out enough a
month-long news cycle
hundreds of news stories millions of
people denouncing her
repeated tearful apologies none of that
was enough
because nothing is ever enough they had
to bring rachel on the air again
to humiliate and degrade her some more
now rachel as far as i know was not
kidnapped and forced to take part
in this spectacle at gunpoint she
volunteered for it
for whatever reason perhaps still
believing in her hopeless naivete
that eventually if she apologizes enough
she'll be forgiven and allowed to just
move on with her life
what she doesn't realize didn't realize
still somehow does not realize
is that she can't be forgiven because
there's nothing to forgive
and the people she's asking for
forgiveness from were not harmed or
injured by her in any way so they can't
provide her with forgiveness
this is not about any alleged sin she
committed and never was
she's not a person okay she's not an
individual named rachel in the eyes of
the cancel mob
she is rather a white woman or more to
the point
a representative of whiteness and her
job is to be chastised and humiliated
and they'll keep doing that to her as
long as she offers herself up to be the
ceremonial sacrifice so let's take a
look at how the ceremony played out last
night
rachel's brought on stage given yet
another opportunity to apologize
um somehow the apology needed to be
given specifically to matt
james who somehow has become the special
victim
of a party that rachel went to three
years ago before she knew him
now if it were me ask to apologize to
matt james over something like that
my apology would sound something like
this i would say hi matt james
i'm sorry that you're a huge baby please
get over yourself
and that would be it and if rachel had
said that
i would be ready to build a statue in
her honor
and defend it from the mobs that come to
tear it down but that is certainly not
what rachel said instead she said this
let's listen
i think that you know everything up to
this point i think that you know
exactly how i feel and
i really just want to take the time to
say i'm really sorry
and once i really tried to
to put myself into your shoes as much as
i could
i really do think that
our relationship was very strong and the
love that we shared was very real so for
you to
to end things i
i realized that that must have been
really hard for you as well to where
you must have been hurting and i just
wanted to say i'm really sorry for
not understanding that initially um
and then i'm really sorry that i hurt
you
the love that we shared was very real
yeah the love was as real as anything
else that's going on here and all the
other emotions on display as real as
that
it would be so uncomfortable for me to
be
matt james accepting this apology
from someone who didn't do anything to
me like it would be hard for me to do
and keep a straight face the entire time
i would have trouble doing that
but he is such a narcissist that he
actually thinks he deserves this apology
and so that's how he's able to to
stomach this and to keep a straight face
so was that enough had she finally
apologized enough not remotely
matt james a grown man was left tearful
and speechless due to the trauma he
suffered and is still suffering from a
picture of a 21 year old chick
at a frat party the host gave james some
time to collect himself
but you know he could he could barely
speak and he he tried to
he just was so overcome with emotion
because of this picture from a frat
party three years ago
uh he was trying to offer some kind of
response and this was all that he could
get out let's watch
matt how uh
how hard is this on you just seeing
the woman that you love that you loved
i'm so torn up over hurting you
and over losing you
i
um
it's it's heartbreaking and it's
devastating
it's
it's just it's just disappointing
so
matt there's so much more on your heart
i don't even want to i don't even want
to interject i can see it in your eyes
what else do you want to share with her
uh
he can't get it out he just he can't
it's so difficult for him this is so
hard
this is so hard for matt james so how
hard is this for you matt james how hard
is it for you
that this woman's life is over and that
you helped make that happen
how hard is it for you that you had to
throw her under the bus was that really
hard for you
that bus was coming and and you you
you had to make the choice to pick her
up and chuck her right under it
right so the wheel just went right over
her skull that had to be is that hard
for you
must've been so hard so so hard
if you didn't know the context you might
think that rachel had shot matt's dog
or burned his house down or at least
victimized him personally in some way
and in fact even if she had burned his
house down i would still say
that he needs to pull himself together
and act like a man
but in reality she didn't do a single
damn thing to him at all remember this
man was a football player
though he never made it off the practice
squad maybe this is why
they didn't want some whiny crying wimp
in the locker room
now eventually i can report matt did
pull himself together enough
to manage to communicate in full
sentences and his message was that he's
hurt
and he's disappointed and he's not ready
to forgive
he's not ready he's so traumatized by
this picture from a frat party three
years ago
he thinks about it every day he's he's
losing sleep over it he's tossing and
turning
at night talking to himself the frat
party picture i can't sleep
she has a lot of work to do he said
she's got a lot of work to do
he has this amoral
soulless narcissist he has no work to do
but she has a lot of work to do and he
can't do that work for her
he said she's got to do it herself then
she tried to hug him
and he turned her down as the last in
dignity
so they brought on this white woman
purely to humiliate her
and to humiliate her for being a white
woman because that is her real crime
here let's be clear
that's what she did wrong well you're
seeing what
in that picture what she's doing wrong
is having that skin tone
and yet everyone else on the stage is
the victim
not her and actually i agree with that
last part at least she's not a victim
they certainly aren't but neither is she
this is self-inflicted
she has volunteered for this position
offered herself up for it repeatedly
this is how canceled culture survives
and thrives
this is the fuel that sustains it
it needs not just people to cancel
and it's got a never-ending supply of
those and it can cancel anybody any time
but that's not enough it needs people
who will go along with the whole
ceremony the whole charade
right for for the whole human sacrifice
it's like the aztecs when they when they
had a human sacrifice brought them up
the temple
put them down on the slab cut their
heart out held the heart up cut off
their limbs rolled their body
down the temple steps it was a whole
ceremony they had to do
and it's a kind of similar thing here
because the difference is the aztecs
would actually just
put you in chains and bring you up the
top you didn't really have a choice
here though they're not putting you in
chains you have to volunteer you have to
come out and say all right i'm here
rip my heart out
they need people who will lay down and
be carcasses for the vultures to pick
apart
and it's never gonna stop it will never
stop until we
until we all stop volunteering for that
role
until we all look at the mob and say i
don't apologize
i will never apologize i don't care how
you feel and by the way please kiss my
ass
that's the only way that's the only
appropriate response
that's the only moral response to these
lunatics
that's the only way that any of this
stops now let's get to our five
headlines
let's say about our sponsors policy
genius no before policy genius existed
it was uh
really hard to quickly find affordable
life insurance a lot of hoops you had to
jump through a lot of red tape you had
to clear
a lot of a lot of other things you had
to deal with but now we have policy
genius makes it a lot easier
and we know that spring is uh springing
as we speak and it's a perfect reminder
to tidy up and get your life in order
why not start by protecting your family
with life insurance policy genius can
help
you compare top insurers in one place
and say 50 or more
once you find your best option the
passive genius team will set up your
policy for you and answer any questions
you have along the way
there's no excuse not to do it because
they make it so easy and so cheap here's
how you get started first head to
policygenius.com in minutes you can work
out
how much coverage you need and compare
quotes to find your best price policy
genius
makes it easy to compare policies from
as little as 15 a month
you might even be eligible to skip the
in-person medical exam but you got to go
and find out first
and the policy genius they have a
five-star rating across thousands of
reviews on trustpilot and google there's
a reason for that it's a great service
so
while you're tidying up around the house
this spring why not get your life
insurance organized too you could save
50
or more by comparing quotes and feel
good knowing that it's something
if something happens your loved ones
will be taken care of so go to
palsygenius.com to get started
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right
so the fallout from the vatican
confirming that the catholic church is
still catholic continues it's been a lot
of
speaking of people being devastated and
heartbroken and disappointed
you know a lot of people have been
saying that even so-called
catholics i just read a headline from a
jesuit
publication of course saying that so
many catholics
quote unquote big air quotes around it
so many catholics are disappointed
in the catholic church because catholic
church announced yesterday
that um according to the catholic church
there still cannot be gay marriage they
can't sanction or bless gay marriage
marriage is between a man and a woman
that's the biblical view
that's been the catholic view for 2 000
years and it still is
hasn't changed so it wasn't so much an
announcement as
uh simply an affirmation of what has
been the case for 2000 years
a continued affirmation of this thing
that has been the case all along
but it's being treated like breaking
news and so many people are disappointed
not because again not because
they didn't know the catholic church's
position
i mean everybody knew right
but because they assumed
that the catholic church an institution
that's been around for two for two
for uh two millennia would
would change would would would change
according to
the left's whims they assumed that it
would
because everybody else does and everyone
and everything else is
everything else is changing because the
left demands it
and they assume the catholic church
would do the same catholic church isn't
and so they don't know how to handle
that
here's don lemon don lemon had quite a
take about this
here's don lemon putting on his
theologian hat
and giving a little bit of a theological
perspective here's what he had to say
you got engaged to your fiance tim in
2019
and this morning and you guys are so
cute we learned that the vatican has
said that the catholic church
won't bless same-sex unions quote since
god cannot bless sin
they go on to say that this does not
imply a judgment on persons
but i want to know do you think this
sends a damaging message and how do you
feel about that given that obviously
you are now engaged and going to get
married well i think
there are listen i respect people's
right to believe in whatever they want
to believe in their god but if you
believe in something that
hurts another person that or that does
not give someone
the same rights or freedoms not
necessarily under the constitution
because this is
under god i i think that that's wrong
and i think that the the catholic church
and many other churches
really need to re-examine themselves and
their teachings because
that is not what god is about god is not
about hindering people
or even judging people now as far as i
know
don lemon and yeah we'll get to that
last line in just a second i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna just
leapfrog over that but as far as i know
don lemon
is not catholic
um so what why are we bringing him on to
get his reaction to this
and why is he being asked you know how
it affects him how do you feel how does
it affect you
how are you feeling now the catholic
church what do you care who cares who
cares how he feels about it he's not
even catholic
makes a difference and even if he is
catholic still who cares
oh but he but don lemon wants to be
clear you know he respects everyone's
rights
to their beliefs right um
but your belief should align with his
own
that's the one little qualifier little
little detail he respects all your
beliefs
and you should be able to have whatever
beliefs you want as long as they are his
beliefs
that's all it's not too much to ask is
it
just simply align yourself with
everything that don lemon believes and
then you could have rights
but then he says of course that god is
not about judgment
which is a really really insightful and
convincing take as long as you don't
read
literally any page of the bible
because all you have to do and i mean
any page doesn't matter
pick a page at random pick up the bible
skim to any page at all old testament
new testament
and you're going to find god judging
references to god judging it's all over
the text because as it turns out god is
very much about judgment
very much that see that that's part of
the whole
religion deal at least at least a
theistic religion as opposed to the
godless cult-like religion of leftism
which don lemon of course subscribes to
and he thinks that that should be the
only religion anyone should have
but in um in uh what are we so
what are we gonna call it traditional
abrahamic religion
uh yes god is certainly about judgment
but don lemon feels fine this is any any
left especially in the media
you know again they they think that and
this is what they really believe
they honestly believe that they should
be able to
sit there in front of the camera and
simply tell the catholic church what its
teaching should be
they can wave away two thousand years of
teaching they say how cares about two
thousand years of
thomas aquinas who cares about him throw
all that away
i'll tell you what your teaching should
be
i've literally never even read the bible
but i will still tell you
how you should interpret the bible and
according to don lemon the best way to
interpret the bible is to
chuck it into the incinerator to ignore
it
um jen saki by the way was asked
about this at the white house press
conference yesterday about the vatican
and uh said you know what what is the
white house's response she didn't have
much of a response but she affirmed that
biden does continue to support uh
same-sex marriages
even while being such a devout a
wonderful catholic he's a devout
catholic
buddy but at the same time he supports
same-sex marriages
nobody's we're never gonna get that
that thing where someone in the media
actually asks joe biden
how how do you square these two things
so you're a devout catholic you believe
in in
in the catholic church supposedly
and yet you reject the church's
moral authority on a really fundamental
level
right we're not talking about you have a
disagreement no you you reject the
the church's teachings on abortion and
marriage
those are the one the two foundational
pillars of um
catholic morality christian morality and
you reject that
so in what way are you a devout catholic
you think the church is wrong about this
okay so you think the church has
no special moral authority okay so
you're not a catholic
and you don't have to be you're free to
be anybody any any religion you want
but you can't be a catholic while
ejecting the moral
authority of the church
by definition you can't be in the same
way that you can't be a bachelor and
still be married
it's not like there's a law saying you
can't be a married bachelor
it's not it's not it's not a law written
in a book it's a logical requirement
if you are one you can't be the other
you can't be a catholic who rejects the
authority of the church
number two governor cuomo speaking of
catholics who reject the authority of
the church
is still not resigning i said he's not
going to resign even with all the extra
pressure
and here's what he had to say in
explaining his decision to remain
defiantly in office this is what he said
people know the difference between
playing
politics bowing to cancel
culture and the truth
let the review proceed i'm not going to
resign
yeah i want to be clear that is not
canceled culture so
we do have a problem of people
appropriating
to use a popular term uh the the cancel
culture
concept and we're getting this a lot
from politicians too
that they're victims of cancel culture
and we hear it on the right and the left
that's not canceled culture when you're
embroiled in a scandal
and governor cuomo has two of them one
being
way more serious than the other one
because one involving the deaths of
thousands of elderly people
and the other involving inappropriate
comments made to women so
but he's got two of them and he's
embroiled in that and
and he's and he's facing backlash for
that that's happened to politicians
since time immemorial
that is not cancelled culture and if
you're a politician on either side
you're always going to have people who
want who want you out of office who are
it's their whole their whole job is to
try to dig up dirt about you destroy you
you volunteer for that when you become a
politician that's not cancelled culture
cancel culture again there are certain
hallmarks of it and it is a uniquely
it's a uniquely modern phenomenon and
it's uniquely leftist
there may have been you go through
history there have been ver the salem
witch trials there have been versions of
uh of if you want to call cancel culture
but
in our in what we're referring to in
modern society
and as i've said many times it's very
clear it's very important to clarify
cancel culture is a leftist phenomenon
because it's all about institutional
power and they have the power to
because they control the institutions
they can control your
destroy your career destroy your
reputation
expel you from civilized society they
have the power to do that
conservatives even if they wanted to do
it can't do it
so conservatives even if they wanted to
have their own canceled culture
don't have it because they don't have
the power
we don't have the power leftists do
and we also know another really
important part of canceled culture
is that it is performative and
fraudulent
and you're destroying people
who either didn't do anything wrong
or even if they did do something wrong
the response to that infraction
is way out of proportion
and the canceling is being spearheaded
by people who are not really affected by
it
in this case there's nothing out of
proportion here especially given again
that first scandal that involved
killing a bunch of elderly people trying
to remove him from office is not out of
proportion at all so that's not
cancelled culture
all right number three sad news to
report this from the daily wire it says
gun control activist
david hogg pledged to launch a
progressive competitor to my pillow
but just one month after the company's
soft launch
so to speak good pillow which is what he
wanted to call it has yet to debut a
product and the good pillow trademark
belongs to someone else so
it's only been one month uh but
especially because i guess he never
trademarked good pillow
he announced that that's a that's a
rookie mistake i'm no businessman myself
but i'm
that that much i know if you're gonna
announce something like that and
you want to get the trademark first he
didn't get the trademark someone else
took it
and it looks like good pillow is not
going to happen i'm very disappointed by
that
turns out that a pillow company
started out of spite and purely for
political reasons a politically
motivated pillow company
not going to have a lot of success it
turns out
and you could say that we know my pillow
you know there's the the the owner of my
pillow has a political viewpoint
but the company wasn't founded on that
basis
it was founded in order to provide good
pillows to people actual good pillows
if politics is your whole point and not
the product
it's not gonna be a good start all right
number four this is from page six it
says elliott page revealed
that and i'm gonna read i'm reading from
the article so this is this is why
this is the language they're using
elliot page revealed he
underwent top surgery as part of his
transgender journey
the umbrella star academy star said the
surgery which removes breast tissue to
produce a more masculine appearance
was life-changing he told time magazine
it has completely transformed my life
page said the surgery didn't define
being trans but provided him with
freedom
from the total hell that was puberty and
allowed him to finally
recognize himself when he looks in the
mirror okay that's page six
um so elliott page
which i have no problem saying because
again you can you can choose whatever
name you want
elliott page uh removed her breasts now
what i'll say this to me seems really
really common sense
it should be illegal for doctors to
remove the body parts
amputate body parts from physically
healthy people
that should not be legal to do that
and this is not about restricting what
individuals can do to themselves it's
about restricting
what a doctor can do to someone else and
there are all kinds of laws
governing that right there are all kinds
of laws determining
what a doctor can do to somebody and
there needs to be laws
this should be one of those laws
if i walk into the doctor's office and
say
hey can you chop off my left arm
and it turns out that there's nothing
wrong with my left arm whatsoever
there is no circumstance where they
should actually do it or be allowed to
do it
if i want my left arm chopped off that's
an indication that there's
there is something wrong and assuming
it's not
physical if they find out it's not
physical yes there is something wrong
but
but there's something going wrong in my
brain
and so that's what needs to be treated
the correct response from a doctor would
be to get me into counseling we could
look into other kinds of medication
to find out what the real issue is here
but we know that the real issue is not
my arm
so there's no scenario where the doctor
should actually take my arm off
if there's a mental issue it should be
treated on that basis
i said this on twitter earlier and a
whole bunch of people including
so-called conservatives
rushed in to defend a doctor's right to
amputate healthy body parts from
physically healthy people
because that's what conservatism is now
we're even conserving that i suppose
and one of the arguments i encountered
was that well this is a
this is just like plastic surgery would
you say that plastic surgery should be
illegal
now personally it wouldn't bother me
that much if they're if if we did have
some more laws governing
even plastic surgery because i think
there's a lot of um
i think the plastic surgeons can
oftentimes take advantage of people
you know someone who's had 50 procedures
already and doesn't even look human
anymore from all the plastic surgery
they obviously have mental issues
that person comes in for more surgery
yeah i think that there should be a
cut-off point where the doctor has to
say just like a bartender is going to
cut you off
even though you're you know you are an
adult consenting adult
at a certain point the doctor's going to
say the the bartender is required to say
no we can't serve you anymore
we can't so yeah i'd be fine if there
were more
more laws governing that with plastic
surgeons but we don't even have to get
into that because this is a very
different thing
see i would say that there is
definitionally a huge difference
between
enhancing quote unquote someone's body
part with silicon or whatever
and removing a body part
and the difference is kind of like the
difference between getting a tattoo on
your skin
and having your skin peeled off
if i went to the tattoo artist and said
no you know my whole arm can you just
take all the skin right off
i think the tattoo artists should be
legally required to say no i'm not going
to do that
but if you want to put something on my
skin fine not everyone would agree with
that decision but yes that is a decision
that uh
a person should be free to make i think
there's a pretty clear distinction there
uh so i just think that this is a it's
it's a sad story
about elliot page and there are a lot of
sad stories like
this number five the pacific daily news
reports
um delegate michael sand nichols and the
guam national guard
visited representative marjorie taylor
green after she falsely suggested that
guam
is a foreign territory unworthy of aid
representative marjorie taylor green
georgia republican suggested that guam
was a foreign land during a speech
at the conservative political action
conference 2021 in florida
and the response here
from the delegate is to bring the guam
national guard in
uh to talk to marjorie taylor and they
got it on film
so this this this politician is walking
and he's got he's flanked by these
national guardsmen using them as
political props
in order to score a dunk on uh on
marjory taylor green
so this is yet again this has been the
theme over the last two weeks
is the military being used as political
props and using itself
as political props volunteering to be
used in that way
we're only two months in and the
military under joe biden has managed to
disgrace
itself in truly unprecedented ways
we have not seen anything like this
uniform military personnel in official
capacities
openly being openly political
that's what we get from joe biden's
administration all right let's move on
to reading
the youtube comments max says
the military removing their gender
neutral physical test is just like
affirmative action but for gender
lowering expectations in the name of
inclusivity that's exactly what it's
like that's exactly right
uh mario says i'm just commenting to see
if it gets on reading the youtube
comments
i'm a generous man and i've major no
doubt made your life
mario you can die a happy man you have
made it onto reading the youtube
comments
anna says matt you would be so proud of
me i was going through the drive through
the other day to get coffee
and when i got to the window to pay the
woman informed me that the car in front
of me paid for my drink
i responded that's awesome still holding
my drink she hesitated as if she
expected me to say that i would pay for
the person behind me
instead i reached out and she
reluctantly handed me my drink i told
her to have a great day and drove away
smiling
because i broke the chain well done
thank you
thank you ma'am anna for your service
this is what people need to do
rising up as one voice against the uh
pay it forward drive through chains
accept the charity right someone someone
paid for your drink accept it
that's the right thing to do actually
uh and uh and go about your day so well
done
um keenan says matt didn't you say that
daylight savings was stupid because it
was just a new zealand man who was
trying to collect bugs he had a lot of
people calling me out on this yesterday
i
i came out in favor of daylight savings
time um
and said i'm a fan of it on the basis of
it's a tradition it's the tradition of
our forefathers a mysterious tradition
nobody knows exactly why we do it but we
do it
and you know i think there's something
quite beautiful about that and i got
called out by a lot of people in the
comments pointing out that a year ago
i came out against daylight saving time
and said it was incredibly stupid we
should stop doing it
well you know what i am free to change
my mind
i have evolved as a person
i've i've learned to see things through
a new perspective
and you have to give me a room to do
that you have to give me room to grow as
a person
and i'm not going to apologize for that
and you're banned from the show
uh lush uncut says your pronunciation of
megan the stallion is probably the
funniest thing i've heard
thus far this week i don't know what
you're referring to i don't know what's
wrong with my that's how you pronounce
your
name
so before we get to our daily
cancellation i want to tell you about
the true underdog podcast
raised in trailer park with no clear
path to success kicked out of high
school multiple times and faced with
becoming a father and his teens jason
waller
is the definition of a true underdog
after hearing the words no or you can't
too many times
he unleashed the power within to start
three successful companies with his most
recent venture power home solar
skyrocketing on a path to becoming a
billion dollar enterprise
so you can join waller a four-time
entrepreneur of the year as he shares
motivational tips and
inspiring stories and business building
lessons from the ground up he shares his
life experiences
and that of his high profile guests to
help others better themselves
now as waller will tell you there is no
elevator to success the climb only
happens one step at a time
so you can let every true underdog
podcast be the step that elevates you we
can learn about failure
learn about entrepreneurship learn about
never quitting or making excuses
learn all the tips and secrets that you
need to build your own successful
business and learn it from the experts
it's real it's raw it's motivational
it's what you need to hear so here's
what you need to do check out
true underdog podcast at
trueunderdog.com or anywhere
you get your podcasts and you know we've
been talking about
this for a while now but we're finally
here
candace candace owens new show which is
called candace appropriately
is debuting on friday march 19th it's
the premiere of the show
and we're so excited for you guys to
check it out i'm so excited to see it
myself
it's no secret that candice has ruffled
some feathers along her career we all
know that
and you know she gets people talking and
she's going to do that with this show so
you want to be a part of that
and if you and if you're going to be a
part of it what you have to do is
uh become a daily wire member because
the show is exclusive to daily wire
members if you aren't a member yet go to
dailywire.com
subscribe and use code candice for 25
off that's dailywire.com
subscribe use code candace for 25
off now let's get to our daily
cancellation
so today we have a number of people to
cancel all starting with and connected
to meghan markle
who is also canceled and we'll begin
with the latest markle news according to
various media reports markle is planning
to run for president uh these reports
actually go back several months as
she's reportedly been been networking
with democrats for a while now putting
together a team
her plan we're told is to jump into the
race if biden
doesn't run for a second term and we
know that by 2024 biden will most likely
be wheelchair-bound and catatonic
which would seem to preclude him from
another run then again with modern deep
fake technology maybe a little bit of
ventriloquism
they might be able to have him run even
in that state we don't know but in any
case the point is that markle has eyes
on the presidency
and this raises a few questions
principally what exactly has this
ridiculous woman done
in her life to qualify her for the
presidency
she acted on the usa network then
divorced her husband and married a
prince
that's the extent of her resume i'm not
sure that's enough to qualify her to be
the assistant manager at pottery barn
much less the president united states
the other question is
how does a presidential campaign fit
with megan and harry's professed
desire for privacy i mean something
seems a little off here
megan says that she was traumatized by
all the media attention and scrutiny
so her solution was to move to hollywood
sign a netflix deal
do a prime time interview with oprah and
then run for president
i mean it's almost as if this woman far
from being traumatized by the attention
actually desires it more than she
desires anything else in the world
it's almost as if this woman in other
words is totally full of crap
but of course you can't say that because
this woman in addition to being an
attention-starved fraud
also has a magical bubble around her
that protects her from criticism
she is a victim despite being richer
than you more famous than you
more powerful than you you still owe her
your pity
if you don't want to have pity for her
then the other approved emotion the only
other approved emotion
you're allowed to have is admiration
pity or admiration or both
and admittedly it's a strange
combination it might seem difficult to
see somebody as both
a sad and pitiful character and also
strong and impressive and admirable
like it's kind of for me it's one of the
other but
this is often how it goes these days in
a culture that idolizes victimhood
now this bubble around meghan markle
must be respected
those who don't respect it those who
would dare publicly criticize
her her royal highness the queen of all
victims will face
serious repercussions for example piers
morgan as you've probably heard
was forced to step away from his
position on the show good morning
britain
after criticizing meghan markle and he
was a repeat offender we should note
he repeatedly criticized our blessed
mother markle
and such blasphemy could not be allowed
to stand
but as we've learned if someone is
accused that we just talked about the
getting the show
if someone is accused of being racist
and of course pierce morgan
is racist for disliking meghan markle
because that's literally the only reason
that anyone could possibly dislike her
but if somebody is accused of that crime
you will also reveal yourself to be a
racist if you defend that person that's
how the dominoes fall
and that is why now sharon osborne
co-host of the talk
on cbs finds herself at the center of a
public firestorm in a recent episode
osborne
who's friends with morgan made the
mistake of defending him from
baseless slander the conversation with
her co-host cheryl underwood got pretty
heated
uh and they were disagreeing god forbid
let's listen to that
i want you to hear from me i will ask
you again
cheryl i've been asking you during the
break i am asking you again
and don't try and cry because if anyone
should be crying it should be me
this is the situation you tell me where
you have
heard him say educate me tell
me when you have heard him say
racist things educate me tell me
it is not the exact words of racism
it's the implication and the reaction
to it to not want to address
that because she is a black woman and to
try to dismiss it
or to make it seem less than what it is
that's what makes it
racist but but right now i'm talking to
a woman who i believe is my friend and i
don't want anybody here
to to watch this and say that we're
attacking you for being racist
and and that and for that if i
articulate it i think it's
too late i think that's already sold but
that that is why i'm saying for me
i love how british people say again
again
i do like that but anyway sharon um
wanted to be given a specific example of
piers morgan saying or doing something
actually racist
this seems like a reasonable demand if
you're going to publicly accuse
some one of of anything especially
racism the onus is on you to
substantiate that claim
this is not only a moral obligation but
a legal one
if you're going to make an accusation
against somebody publicly you better
have some reason behind it
sharon asked her co-host for
substantiation
and what she was told here's the exact
transcript we just heard that but here's
i think sometimes it helps to look at
the words written out or hear it again
um here's the exact transcript of what
sharon osborne's co-host said to her in
regards to
the proof that uh pierce morgan is
racist
she said it is not the exact words of
racism it's the implication
and the reaction to it to not want to
address
that because she's a black woman and to
dismiss it or to make it seem less than
what it is
that's what makes it racist oh okay well
that's what makes it racist well okay
then
does anyone have any idea what that
means i'm not trying to be funny i
honestly have
no clue how to interpret that it's not
coherent
what does that mean there isn't even one
fully coherent
thought in that sentence or paragraph or
haiku or whatever it was
it's nonsensical and it was a long
nonsensical way of saying
no i have absolutely no evidence to
support my claim that this person's
racist
but i'm going to keep making that claim
anyway sharon osborne was right to be
angry
i would even say it took some courage
and some character to speak up and
defend her friend in that way
i would say that if not for the entirely
predictable events
that ensued from there cbs announced
that it was canceling its live shows for
the first part of this week as it
launches
investigation into that on-air
discussion
they're going to investigate that
discussion that we just watched
what is there to investigate what could
the investigation
possibly consist of are they going to
bring in csi detectives
maybe draw a chalk outline on the stage
to show exactly where
sharon osborne committed emotional
murder of her co-host by disagreeing
with her
who knows all we know is that it's the
lead up to sharon
either being canned or rep reprimanded
in some other way
and and the thing is she knows it there
she said it she's like that's that ship
has sailed you've already accused me of
racism
i'm done and i would again appreciate it
so much if she just realized that and
said you know what you
you've already done it so i'm not gonna
play this game anymore but she didn't
she uh sharon did issue the groveling
apology that everybody expects
she wrote in a statement after some
reflection
after sitting with your comments and
sitting with my heart sitting with my
heart well it's good to sit with your
heart
yeah i think really you should sit with
uh all of your internal organs
um generally when i'm sitting i like to
have them all with me so i don't lose
track of one
i like to sit with my with my my spleen
even my kidney
and my heart but anyway um after sitting
with my heart i would like to address
the discussion
on the tic on the talk this past
wednesday i've always been embraced with
so much love and support from the black
community
and i have deep respect and love for the
black community to anyone of color that
i offended and or to anyone that feels
confused or let down by what i said
i am truly sorry i panicked felt
blindsided
got defensive and allowed my fear and
horror of being accused of being racist
take over
and she went on for several more
sentences about how much she hates
racism i mean she's super duper hates
racism you guys she
really really hates it and
she said she doesn't condone bullying or
misogyny which is a not very veiled way
of throwing the friend that she was just
defending
straight under the bus so much for
courage and character
now keep in mind that sherrod osborne is
almost 70 years old speaking of plastic
surgery
she has a net worth of 200 million
dollars
somehow she could easily tell the
canceled mob to piss off
and and ride off into the sunset and
live the good life for her remaining
years
easily do that but she like almost
everyone else on the public stage has
absolutely no spine
no courage no willingness to sacrifice
even the slightest smallest bit
and is totally desperate for the
approval of her peers and society at
large
i mean you probably wouldn't be hosting
a show like the talk at the age of 70
otherwise
this is how impenetrable the victimhood
force field has become
not only are you not allowed to
criticize someone who's been deemed a
victim
but you can't even defend the people who
do criticize that person
and you can't defend the people who
defend the people who criticize the
purse
no you can't do any of that look every
culture has its idea of the sacred
right every civilization has things that
are untouchable
things that must not be defamed or
sullied and for a strong and thriving
civilization
the sacred is the divine god but for us
in our profane and stupid age
the sacred are the protected classes the
societally appointed victims
they are the ones you must not blaspheme
or else suffer
the fate of an apostate now thankfully
in my case
i've been i've long been an apostate in
the eyes of the
religious cult of leftism so i can
continue along saying apostate things
i've got nothing else to lose and that's
why i can say
meghan markle is certainly canceled and
so is sharon osborne for caving
and cowering and uh everybody else on
the talk to and cbs
and um anyone who watches that show is
canceled and so okay i think that about
summarizes
a lot of cancelling to go around as
always
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day
godspeed
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is our mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledovsky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. liberal
journalists are shocked to discover that
the pope believes in catholicism
cardi b jiggles at the grammys and the
washington post corrects a major lie
about president trump and the 2020
election check it out on the michael
knowles show